today we're going to talk about how to
fix sciatica i've done quite a few
videos on sciatica this is an updated
video
because there's one
stretch
that i think is going to help you the
most so i'm constantly trying to find
faster ways to fix things and less
complexities and this one's very very
simple okay so the first question is
what is sciatica well it's pain that can
come from your lower back that radiates
down legs usually in the back part of
the leg the sciatic nerve is the longest
and widest nerve of the body okay
and it usually
originates
from
l4 to s3 which i'm going to show you
right here here you have five lumbar
vertebras right
one two three four five okay so the
sciatic nerve starts at l4 okay this
nerve right through in here and includes
l5 and then some nerves from this lower
part called the sacrum so all these
nerves form the sciatic nerve that goes
right down to the back of the leg what
you need to know is that 90
the great majority of sciatic nerve pain
involves a disc okay it can also involve
degeneration of the disc where the
vertebra start to become collapsed and
you get these thinner
discs okay and this is why as people get
older they might have more sciatica type
pain now the interesting thing about
disc problems is that when you look on
an x-ray or an mri
and you see a problem with the disc it
nearly always comes with a loss of the
lumbar curve that's called the loss of
lordosis where you have this natural
curve in your lower back so if you have
sciatic pain chances are you've lost the
normal curve in your lower back
so normally it should look like this
and you look like this when you lose the
curve of your lower back you decrease
the space in the spinal column so now
the question is how do we get this curve
back
what you're going to do is you're going
to do a stretch that involves
a foam
support a low back support you can call
it like a foam block or a low back
support but it needs to be firm enough
so when you lay on your back with this
support it gives you significant
pressure
in this direction
to start putting this curve back now you
can use various things this is like
something i found i think at target um
it's a low back
cushion you can use something like that
you can
use something like this i used to sell
these i don't sell them anymore because
you can very easily
buy one of those circular foam
object and then cut it in half okay so
this could be your support you can even
leave the whole thing intact and lay
with your lower back in this area right
here okay or there's other foam devices
you can get that are more corrective for
the lower spine
so you can see this shape right here
okay
so if you were to lay on this
you would lay so your feet going this
way okay and your head going this way
right here and you'd want to lay so the
peak right here
is right at this center point
about l
three or l two
and so when you lay on this cushion
what you're doing
is you're creating this constant
stretching of these ligaments muscles
and tendons now here's the secret are
you ready for this when you lay on this
device
i'd say the first 10 to 15 minutes even
will go so far where it will make you
feel
really good you'll get relief
but it's not going to correct the curve
okay it's kind of like you're just
tapping into the elastic part of your
lower back where it's like a rubber band
and it just gradually comes back
however there is some fantastic research
that talks about increasing the time
laying on the support so if you were to
lay on this support for let's say 20
minutes every day or even a little bit
longer what you're going to find is it's
going to start to correct
this curve because it works on the
deeper ligaments to create like a
remodeling
reshaping of your lower back so what you
want to do every night is lay on this
for about 20 minutes now the problem is
that when you lay on this cushion
your butt probably is going to be raised
up and it's going to be very
uncomfortable at first so maybe you
start with 10 minutes and you gradually
work up to 15 and then maybe 16 minutes
but do it gradually because when you
stand up you're going to feel really
stiff and sore but realize what you're
doing is you're putting this curve back
in slowly over time so you might want to
gradually do it maybe with a pillow
underneath your butt but just keep
working at it every day until you can
hit like 20 minutes and feel comfortable
on the support so even though your
sciatic nerve pain is gone
continue to do this because ideally you
want to correct this curve so it doesn't
come back especially since the number
one killer and the thing that
reverses this lower back curve is
sitting which a lot of people do on
their desk all day and then they watch
tv and they're slouching down and they
lose this curve so this is a way to put
it back now if you haven't seen my video
on low back pain
you should probably check that out i'll
put it up right here check it out